why are you here
i am here because my ex-husband is suing
me
for an op-ed i wrote
and how do you feel about that
i
um
i
struggle to have the words
i struggle to find the words to describe
how
painful this is
um this is horrible
for me to sit here
for
weeks and
relive everything
hear
people that i
knew
some well some not
my ex-husband within my shared a life
um speak um
about our lives in the way that they
have
um
this has been one of this is the most
painful and difficult thing i've ever
gone through
for sure
now
there was a
trial in the uk in july of 2020 where mr
depp had sued the sun newspaper and dan
wooten do you recall that
yes uh and what was your level of
participation in that lawsuit in that
trial
well i was uh not party to that lawsuit
i was
a witness um i i suppose the primary
witness since it dealt with the truth of
the relationship um that i shared with
johnny
and what if any role did you have to
play with respect to for example witness
statements and testifying
objection compound
i said for example
overruled
i had to
write
i think i gave seven witness statements
under oath testimony
i sat on the stand
for four days
under mostly cross-examination
and up until this point it was the
hardest thing i had ever had to do
you